a new poll shows that 53% of Americans
say talking politics with someone they
disagree with is stressful and
frustrating this is surprising it means
there are 47% who don't find talking
politics with someone they disagree with
to be stressful and frustrating I don't
believe it around this time I usually do
a monologue and how to reduce political
tension at Thanksgiving dinner it never
helps no one ever listens and why should
they taking advice from a TV host is
like taking a ride from a stranger it's
risky and you often end up dead so
instead of avoiding politics let's go
all in at Thanksgiving but first you
must find the right way to insert it
into dinner conversation here are some
examples Wow these mashed potatoes are
really hot almost as hot as our economy
which under President Trump grew at a 3
to 4 percent rate looks like we have
more dinner rolls than people much like
jobs under Donald Trump who helped
create 4 million of them in just two
years
so Gramps why don't you carve the turkey
just like president Trump carved our
bloated bureaucracy when he cut 16 rules
and regulations for everyone created
saving us 8 billion dollars hmm looks
like we ran out of gravy much like what
happened to our doctors under Obamacare
thank God Donald Trump repealed that
mandate am i right grandma I'm stuffed
much like the Supreme Court is with two
sterling appointments and judges corsets
and Cavanaugh maybe the kids can clear
the table just like Trump clears the
country of ms-13 honey can you take out
the trash just put it on the curb next
to the Paris climate Accords and that
awful Iran treaty oh I love some pumpkin
pie doesn't the color remind you of
Donald Trump's gorgeous hair so that's
it if you can't avoid politics why avoid
politics instead set the tone and the
table with the truth because if you
don't someone else surely will all right
I'm gonna go to the people who have the
conflicting Thanksgiving table routine
and Jessie do your parents go hard on
you for being an unpaid spokesman for
Donald Trump
[Applause]
very funny I actually thought that was a
really good model of every one of your
better ones I would say the key is
surviving my Thanksgiving is respecting
your elders because you know during the
Bush years I got a little cocky you know
stocks were up the surge worked and my
parents so you know our liberal is that
my grandfather is a communist I really
know we're around the dinner table and
like you know two thousand six or seven
and I started quoting Limbaugh and all
of a sudden he grant far slams his fist
on the table and says you don't know
what drooling screaming whole table went
quiet mom starts to clear but he forgot
he was angry and so the next thing you
know he's a gay Jesse passed the pumpkin
cheesecake but that's what's great about
old people they forget why they're angry
and you just have to learn you know
sometimes it's good to know you know
which bear not to poke you right he's
he's still with this her God rested
whose wedding he was watching how he was
he was still here you would not be
watching the father communist grandad
all right watch so you're the father to
two Republicans and I believe one
liberal am i right that's true okay so
on Christmas does the liberal get better
gifts the liberal is my daughter then
your sons
do you ever end up on teams around the
dinner table with your two sons and and
and you and your daughter teaming up
against them politically you know one of
the things that you'd missed in your
monologue was a lot of people actually
agree on things even if they may be
liberal or conservative it's a lot that
they agree on like you know like
infrastructure like not insulting the
guy who took out bin Laden how about
coming yeah because they what a Crump
say he was a Clinton supporter Clinton
support how about you're not saying that
you're CIA let's just ignore them we
have something better to do we don't
agree with your conclusions or maybe
these are very these are liberal talking
pool yeah that's right at the dinner
table
you say maybe you could say you know a
dinner table with Trump and Vladimir
Putin and was a Kim jong-il you know and
he could say I just believe everything
they say that's good with me whatever
you guys say just pass the turkey mm-hmm
I think that it's impossible not to talk
about politics not only that I think
everyone wants to talk about politics
the difference on Thanksgiving
especially if you're hosting you have to
set the rules right and you have to let
people know don't take things personally
like it's okay if we disagree and and
you can have a competition and you can
even keep score you can have a yellow
pad and a tally with four columns and
hash marks in and whoever gets the best
barbs in gets the biggest piece of pie I
don't have a problem with that at all
but you just you have to let people know
not to take it personally so when
someone says something that you disagree
with don't react like it's a personal
slight and that's how we have to
distance ourselves from politics in this
country it's not the only thing that
defines us and politics as we all know
talking about it it can be verified
passionate but it can also be so much
fun yeah you know Dana no one talks
politics at your place because you're
too busy telling them about Jasper yeah
dogs are the great equalizer actually if
you talk you can always find common
ground with people to talk about your
pets and your love of pets a so if
things get really bad and no one is like
you have that uncomfortable silence you
could bring up a dog I'm actually very
skilled at making sure that everyone
realizes we all agree you and huan'er
are saying the same thing now one year I
had an experiment I wanted to bring up
the most uncomfortable topics that I
possibly could and at that time the two
winners were because it was it was 2003
OJ Simpson and my grandmother was very
upset because a lot of people there was
a very heated conversation of course
this was before the big documentary and
the other was what do you want your
funeral to be like oh that's nice
politics actually yeah you found
something that people will then birthday
so ask people like what was their best
vacation of the year like and then you
talk about travel like there's things to
talk what about what about if I was
Jesse's grandfather and I said these
young people they're so idiotic
my solution drink a lot of wine and play
music really loud and that is the
solution because then you can't hear
anything
that's perfect by the alright